This is time, so we do have forty
two minutes. So that's just for a few
minutes of whatever happens, but feel free to
take it away. Start typing, and best of
luck. Hello. So, yeah,
here we have the cluster. So let's see
the nodes that we have with what's going
on. So yeah. Okay.
So, yeah, let's check the pods that are
running there.
So, yeah, it seems the the pods of
the control plane of the the KubeSystem namespace
are all running and good. So, yeah, that's
good for us.
And, yeah, we have this pod that is
in crash load back, cough state. So probably
this is the one that we have to
fix now. We have the pod that is
failing, so
we can get the logs. So
get the pod the name of the pod.
Okay.
So let's describe
this pod
and see what we have there. I think
yeah. We have a sec SecCon security profile
there.
So Okay. Yeah. If if we have a
permission, then I problem.
Maybe this is related to
to.
Yeah. Yeah. We have the the notation here.
So And it's a custom one, so that's
suspicious too.
Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah, I think we can use
inspector gadget to understand what is going on
with this. Probably,
what is happening here is that the pod
is trying to use a Cisco that is
not allowed by day.
So in order to use Inspector Gadget, we
have to install this in in our cluster.
So, yeah,
the time of recording this video, this is
the latest commit that we have on our
main branch.
Right. So
by doing that, we installed the KubeCTL
client part. What we have to do right
now is to deploy Inspector Gadget in the
cluster. So I'm going to use deploy.
And with KubeCTL applied, we can
install
deploy the, yeah, the gadget in on the
on the cluster.
So, yep,
this is gadget.
I'll be set com.
So this is telling us that
there is a port running on this node,
the default namespace,
and this is in part the port that
was crashing before.
This is the name of the process that
was trying to
perform
a syscall.
This should be
yeah. I'm a little bit confused by the
output here.
This system call is not part of the
clustered spec,
but it's not the reason the pod is
crashing yet yet,
at least.
This is the two breaks
colliding together because
a very unfortunate side effect. But what else
would give you permission to write if it
wasn't a Cisco?
Well, capabilities.
Yeah. Alright. So we can trace capabilities?
This should be good.
Okay. Here we are.
Oh, so we have securitycontestcapability.all.
Yeah. This this is no good. We are
running the pod without any capability. Of course,
this is gonna fail. What we need to
understand right now is what are the capabilities
that are required
by this pod.
So, yeah, I think we can use the
capabilities
gadget to get a list of of the
capabilities that this bot is trying to use.
So we have Kubectl gadget capabilities.
We are only interested on this one.
Oh, here we are. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Got it. That
and, yeah, this is the name of the
container,
the UID,
the PID inside the container.
This is the command that is trying to
do that.
And this should be the capability that this
is trying to use. NetBind service.
Does it look good to you?
Mhmm. Looks good to me. Ta da. Yay.
This is working.
It works.
I mean, saying it's working is a pretty
bold statement. But, you know, you you can
confirm that. Right? We wanted to curl from
30,000
localhost, 30,000. 30 thousand. Yep. We were trying
to to
verify that application is working.
So with this this call
Doesn't seem to work. Connection refused.
So there's there's something else that needs to
be fixed.
So this is
30,000 here,
and this should be The $80.80.
So what's the part?
Maybe we can list the
sockets
that are opening the port to check what
is the what is the real port name
that the port is using.
I like how you don't even look at
the manifest to see if it's got a
container port, and they're like, nope. Let's just
go and list all the ports that they
Excuse me.
I don't trust the manifest.
Let me try something. I think we can
just trace the the whole
namespace,
and that should be fine. Oh, I missed
the gadgets here.
Just deleted the pod.
Okay.
Seems
demonic.
Network.
So it's port six six six. Right? So
okay. What we can do right now is
to edit the service and change the port.
Think that's this is why.
Yep. Yep. Sounds good. Yep. Nice try. Okay.
Something doesn't work.
Another thing doesn't work. Your last break.
I
think
somebody said before that
seccomp wasn't the problem yet.
Can give us a clue.
Yeah. I think that's
I'll let you use that on the whole
namespace. I think this is okay.
I think what's interesting about this is that
Postgres traffic means your request has been received,
and the application is
trying to respond.
Okay. So, yeah, it doesn't seem to be
a problem with the networking
because the traffic is arriving there.
The full connection is established.
So I hadn't seen that TCP connect before.
That's awesome. Okay. I'm sending a request now.
It's shut down.
Can you try to send another request, please,
Diego? So I turn off the JSON output
so this is easier to read in this
small terminal.
Yeah. It is shut down. It was funny
that you said that the JSON is easier
to read.
Okay.
So maybe we need to edit the the
second profile.
And because the shutdown is never called, the
socket is never flushed, and the response is
never sent to the client.
Let's do it in
alphabetic order.
I appreciate that.
Right.
And then the cubel will apply the new
second profile.
Yeah. Yeah. Ta da. This is working. Yay.